now we'll get back to all the things
that we had meant to talk about let's go
to
the philadelphia eagles who are
competing with the dallas cowboys
currently for the basement in the nfc
east they're trying to get out of it
they have the saints coming to town this
weekend not an easy way to turn it
around
and jalen hurts the starting quarterback
for the philadelphia eagles as the
saints
head into town uh look i'm not surprised
by this
when carson wentz got benched against
the packers on sunday and
hertz went in it tells me that whoever
in the organization has been pushing
for hurts finally has won and wentz is
playing poorly
what else do you have to lose maybe this
is what turns
your season around although last year
what turned the season around
was once playing really well even though
everyone else was injured
and they found a way to win four in a
row to win the division i think they've
seen enough from wence sharing to
realize that's not gonna happen
and they're just admitting it even
though this guy's making a ton of money
this year a ton of money next year it's
all guaranteed next year there's some
guarantees going into 2022 as well
that they have to put someone on the
field that they think has a better
chance of winning
i think mike that they hope that he
provides a spark and turns this thing
around but frankly
you're also looking at 2021 you know
we've talked repeatedly and you've
written about it
that carson wentz because of his money
is going to have to be on the roster
next season that doesn't mean he has to
be the starting quarterback
and you really want to know what you
have in this guy who's been sitting on
the bench for most of the season he
didn't play much
uh in those first few games and they
need to see what they have in him do
they need to go out and maybe try to get
a nick foles or somebody else to come in
and be the bridge quarterback or is
jalen hurts really your quarterback of
the future and this gives him a chance
at least a little window here to see
what he has in him
if i believe he is a franchise
quarterback and mike i wasn't surprised
by the decision i was surprised by the
timing of the decision and i think it's
really
stupid on the eagles part to come out
and announce
now that that jalen hurts is going to be
their quarterback
do you remember back sean payton kept
repeatedly saying
i'm not going to tell you whether jason
hill or jameis winston is going to start
and we debated that thing the
entire week and i'm sure i can't
remember who they played that week
uh game planning for falcons were game
planning for both quarterbacks
that to me is the most amazing thing
about this is that they actually
announce it today on a tuesday off day
giving the team they play the entire
week to prepare for jalen hurts where
they would have had to
prepare for two quarterbacks and that's
now not going to happen
coincidentally that topic comes up in my
discussion with sean payton so if you
stick around and watch
the peyton interview you will hear why
he did what he did
and why he ultimately believes when
you're facing a team like the eagles
where the two quarterbacks have roughly
the same skill set
it doesn't matter if you don't know
because your game plan
is roughly the same and i also think
doug peterson at this point when
everyone has low confidence in
philadelphia and things aren't going
well
i think peterson's sufficiently
self-aware to know
he doesn't have the same sway in the
locker room that peyton has
to get everybody to shut the hell up
about it because once someone gets the
first team reps tomorrow
at practice someone's gonna say
something and they're not gonna care
that doug peterson may not like it
because right now the sizzle isn't
connected to doug peterson
i had a thought when we were talking
about carson wentz's future
and i don't know how
much sense this makes but frank reich
was the offensive coordinator
the year that the eagles won a super
bowl the year that carson wentz was
the mvp favorite until he tore his acl
and they've got philip rivers on a year
to year arrangement
i wonder if they could maybe try to
unload carson wentz onto the colts i
mean
they'd have to be willing to take on 25
million dollars in cash
and cap obligations but 25 million
is what they are paying phillip rivers
so
uh there may be something to that there
may be something to that i hadn't
thought of that
until just now i've i've racked my brain
sharing trying to think
where could they put carson wentz and
the one that does make sense to me
is the indianapolis colts and i have
wondered mike
how much of frank wright leaving because
it did coincide with the injury and then
carson wentz coming back from that
injury and it kind of his downfall
how much of it is the injury how much is
it of frank wright not being there
anymore
and how much is it of him not having the
weapons in the offensive line
in front of him and around him and all
of those things i think
are factors but it does make sense from
the standpoint of if frank wright
still thinks a lot of carson wentz for
them to get carson wentz as their
quarterback
philip rivers situation is going to be
complicated a by his age
today is his birthday by the way 39
years old i believe today
and so today's his birthday we know his
age we know
he wants to keep playing or he said he's
wanted to keep playing
but he is going to have to have off
season foot surgery so that complicates
everything in in his free agency and
whether the kohl's decide to resign him
or not
so it does absolutely make sense that
that might be the one
place that you could get rid of carson
wentz if that's what you're looking to
do in the off season
and then the question becomes who's your
quarterback next season
which now or jalen hurts to figure out
if he can be that guy
december 8 a good day for philip rivers
this time
frame though not a good window for
carson wentz how about this it was
december 10
of 2017 when he suffered the torn acl in
a game
at the los angeles rams ending his
season opening the door for nick foles
to become the super bowl mvp
december 9 2018 he exits with a back
injury
that let nick foles take the team to the
brink of the final four
a dropped all shawn jeffrey pass
derailing an opportunity to beat the
saints in their own building and now
december 8
2020 benched for jalen hurts and you
know i keep thinking back to the jay
laser report from the weekend on the fox
pregame show that people in the
organization believe
that carson wentz had his confidence
shattered
by the jalen hurts selection and
hey if that is true if your confidence
is going to be shattered by that
then maybe you don't have what it takes
to be a franchise quarterback in the nfl
look at how aaron rodgers responded
to jordan love being taken in round one
and they trade it up
and if this is true and i don't have any
reason to doubt glazer
it makes you wonder does carson wentz
have
top to bottom inside and out that metal
that toughness
to get it done and we haven't seen him
get it done with the season on the line
because
every time it's happened he's gotten
injured and last year it was that
illegal hit
from jadavian cloudy that knocked him
out of the wild card game we didn't get
to see whether or not
he could lead the eagles to a victory in
the post season so so maybe this is an
important glimpse
for the eagles on the the ultimate
limitations to what carson wentz can do
for them or really anyone else
i listened to his entire press
conference on sunday mike and
you know he said all the right things
and said that that
never factored into his confidence when
they drafted jalen hurts he's still
confident
he's never lost that but something has
happened to carson winston if it's not
his confidence
then the eagles probably have bigger
problems but i don't know if that's
something you can repair or not
and it's going to be interesting to see
from now on the rest of the season into
the off season
if they can repair that confidence or
whatever was shattered with carson wentz
because we remember back to the 2017
season before his acl injury against the
rams and
he was an mvp candidate he looked like
one of the best quarterbacks in football
which is why the eagles signed him to
that huge extension
and he just hasn't been the same guy
particularly over the last
year and a half uh he's just struggled
and
uh maybe it is the the lack of
playmakers around him the lack of an
offensive line he doesn't trust his
offensive line getting hit so much with
so many injuries
i don't know but this isn't the same guy
we saw in 2017.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports